let's see the steps to create an AWS
account the first step is to open the
AWS web page then click create a free
account to display the sign in or create
an AWS account page
in this page click I am a new user
enter your email id or mobile number in
the email or mobile number box and then
click sign-in using secure server the
AWS servers verify if an account already
exists with the entered email ID if yes
it displays an error message else
displays the login credentials page
you
in the login credentials page enter the
name re-enter the previously entered
email ID
and the password for your account then
click create account to display the
contact information page
you
this page gives you the option to create
a company account or a personal AWS
account for this demonstration we will
create personal AWS account then enter
your full name and address in the
displayed fields
you
next enter the CAPTCHA characters from
the displayed security image
an important step is to open the AWS
agreement and read it thoroughly
then select the AWS customer agreement
checkbox
selecting the checkbox indicates that
you have read the AWS agreement and you
agree to it then click create account
and continue to display payment
information page in this page enter the
credit card details and then click
verify card and continue to display the
identity verification page before
displaying the identity verification
page the AWS servers verify the entered
credit or debit card details by
performing a reversible transaction of a
small amount
you
this page displays your entered mobile
number and is used to verify and confirm
your identity as you click call me now
the AWS system calls you on the
displayed number and your computer
screen displays a four digit
verification pin enter the displayed
four digit pin in your phone using the
keypad once the verification is
successful the page displays a message
identity verification complete simply
click continue to select your support
flag to display the support plan page
this page displays and explains about
the three support plans basic developer
and business for this demonstration we
will select the free or basic plan and
then click continue to display the
welcome page of the AWS services
congratulations you have successfully
created in AWS account